i graduated in 2014 we were the 911
generation our lives essentially started
after 911 we lived through the 2009
financial collapse here in the States a
lot of us and our parents were living
paycheck to paycheck at that time when
you hear about senator Rubio talk about
his family coming from Cuba and being
the son of a bartender to made living
paycheck to paycheck and not having
silver spoons now a lot of us can relate
to that and him being young gives us
something to look forward to in to the
future we can relate to his energy we
can relate to the story I think that's
really important for Millennials I'm so
excited about this election may usually
being United about this one I say that
the problems that we have in this
country are not going to be solved by
our next president they're gonna be
solved by how US Congress our president
and other branches of government work
together now I know that a lot of you
are disappointed about the direction of
America
because this is the greatest country in
the history of the world and it is not
fulfilling its potential it's being held
back I think senator Rubio knows what
he's doing is a strong conservative he
has experience in Florida and in the US
and I believe 110% that he's up for the
job